the world's humanitarian response system
is being tested to its limits that is
the warning coming from the United
Nations tonight as it launches the
largest appeal for Aid funding in its
history the un's humanitarian office is
asking for a record 51.5 billion dollars
for 2023 as multiple crises and the
ongoing war in Ukraine keep driving up
the Need For assistance the un's global
humanitarian overview says 339 million
people will need humanitarian Aid next
year that is four percent of the world's
population now let that sink in
the un's aid Chief says for so many
people on the brink this appeal is a
lifelong
so the next year is going to be the
biggest humanitarian program in the
world the Gap is because of the needs
not because of the funding
and the needs are going up because we've
been smitten
by the war in Ukraine by covid by
climate
and I fear that 2023
is going to be a an acceleration of all
those Trends and that's why we say in
this report and generally that we hope
2023 will be a year of solidarity just
as
2022 has been a year of suffering
I want to pull in now Alexandra Sayeed
she's head of humanitarian policy and
advocacy had saved the children she
joins me tonight from Washington it's
good to have you with us so yeah what we
just heard there not not very uplifting
a record number of people in need of Aid
a record appeal for Aid funding more
than 50 billion dollars the un's aid
Chief Martin Griffith
calling it a depressing number
does it depress you as well
it's it's awful I mean the global
humanitarian uh plan has shown that 2023
is on record to be the bleakest year
ever in regards to humanitarian needs
uh 339 million people that's one in
every 23 persons on the planet need
humanitarian assistance simply to
survive simply to survive and this is
due to a convergence of crises as you
mentioned we have grinding conflict in
many parts of the world we have a deadly
climate crisis which is fueling drought
in places like Somalia flooding in
places like Pakistan we have Rising
Health epidemics there are places in the
Middle East where cholera was previously
under control and now we're seeing
outbreaks and then of course you can't
underestimate the the aftermath of
covid-19 the impact that that's had on
economic systems and the disruption to
economic systems and all of this has
caused record levels of hunger record
levels of displacement and worsening
poverty driving enormous needs on the
ground yeah and with high inflation
energy costs food costs I mean the price
tag for providing humanitarian Aid is
skyrocketing how is that impacting Aid
organizations such as yours
well it's impacting eight organizations
to others because it
there are there's a a massive gap
between humanitarian needs and the
resources available to respond to those
needs so the system is completely
overstretched we're responding to older
crises like Syria worsening crises like
Afghanistan new crises Yemen
Ukraine which is has just deteriorated
just deteriorated and has really
overstretched the system like never
before so we need to respond differently
we need to respond early we know that
that responding in anticipation of
Crisis is what helps people get through
it and it is ultimately what saves lives
we can't let
warning signs of food shortages and and
risk of famine be ignored we need
Collective action we need it to to
happen now and we just can't afford to
wait we need assistance to get to
Frontline Aid workers that are on the
ground with the acceptance and the
access and communities to respond
quickly and we need this to happen
immediately but you know what I'm saying
I have to correct you know we're already
ignoring it we've been ignoring you last
year the U.N collected less than half of
its Target amount I mean that's a
massive funding yeah so clearly the
system is not keeping Pace with what
these Global emergencies actually cost
and what they demand I'm wondering where
is the capacity then for even more to be
provided when we can't even keep up with
what we need right now
you're absolutely right and this is why
we're also in addition to advocating for
more assistance we're also asking for
more humanitarian diplomacy to end these
crises that's ultimately what's going to
help protect children that's gonna
what's gonna be what's help protect
helps protect civilians that's going to
be what provides some sustained Services
it's not just funding it's not just
assistance we need governments to muster
up the political will to find Solutions
let me let me ask you back in about the
money I mean because we know that the
U.S provides about half of the U.N
budget and there will be a lot of talk
there about whether or not the Americans
are going to provide more but do you see
other sources around the world of money
that have not been tapped I mean there
are countries that have huge Sovereign
wealth funds I mean they would never
even miss it they if they financed the
U.N for the next decade do you see those
countries stepping up to the plate
I think they need to step up to the
plate we there's no there's no other
option if we want to avert further
deaths for their crises they need to
step up to the plate uh we need to see
governments provide their fair share in
terms of assistance
um and and it needs to happen
immediately I mean there's no other
option
um at the moment it's all hands on deck
or else we're gonna see it even Bleaker
2024. yeah I mean it's it's hard to look
at these numbers already and imagine
that things could get even worse
Alexander we appreciate your time and
your insights and the work that you do
it's it's valuable thank you
thank you so much